THINKS THAT THE THINGS DEMOCRATS
ARE PUTTING OUT OR TOO CRAZY.
KELLYANNE CONWAY FORMER
COUNSELOR OF PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
A FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
I LOVE HOW THE MEDIA ALWAYS
TALKS ABOUT THESE SKETCHY
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES CAMINO,
QUALITY CANDIDATES IS AN ISSUE
THIS YEAR FOR REPUBLICANS, HAS
THE MEDIA SEEN WHO THE DEMOCRATS
ARE PUTTING OUT THERE, KELLY
AND?
>> THAT'S THE IRONY, JESSE, BOTH
PARTIES HAD ROBUST PRIMARIES,
OBVIOUSLY THE HIGHER TURNOUT IN
REPUBLICAN PRIMARIES WHICH HAS A
VERY GOOD REPUBLICAN MIDTERM
SUCCESS, BUT TO THE DEMOCRATS,
NOMINATED THE MOST UNELECTABLE
FRINGED OUT OF TOUCH COME OUT OF
SYNC CANDIDATES.
BETTY JOHN OVER IN PENNSYLVANIA
HAS A GREAT EXAMPLE, THIS GUY
HAS A NO-SHOW JOB AS LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR COME THE AP RAN A STORY
LAST WEEK THAT HE FAILED TO SHOW
FOR ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
PRESIDING STATE PROVIDER OF THE
STATE SENATE, HE MAKES $169,000
A YEAR, THE AVERAGE PENNSYLVANIA
HOUSEHOLD MAKES LESS THAN 70,000
AND GAVE HIM MONEY FOR HER FOR
NOT BEING A PRIVATE SECURITY
DETAIL PERKS, AND DON FEDERMAN
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO TAKE IT TO
THE BANK.
HE IS PRO-CRIMINAL,
ANTI-FRACKING, AND HAND TOM WOLF
HAVE LEFT, THEY HAVE LEFT TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PENNSYLVANIA
STUDENTS, 40,000 JUST IN
PHILADELPHIA ALONE, JESSE, ON
THE WAITING LIST FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS URGE SCHOOL CHOICE.
THEY HAVE DONE NOTHING TO HELP
THESE KIDS IN FAILING SCHOOLS TO
EXIT THOSE SCHOOLS AND ACCESS
CHARTER SCHOOLS, SCHOOL CHOICE,
FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY
SCHOLARSHIPS.
NOW HE IS TRYING TO PLAY THE
VICTIM, YOU HAVE THAT "NEW YORK
MAGAZINE" AND OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA TRYING TO
CREATE SYMPATHY FOR HIM, BUT
REMEMBER, I THINK THAT DON
FEDERMAN IS MOST DANGEROUS
PERSON IN PENNSYLVANIA AND IF
YOU THINK THAT THE CRIMINALS ARE
MORE DANGEROUS ASK JOHN FEDERMAN
WHY HE THINKS THEY SHOULD GO
FREE.
LET'S GO OVER TO WISCONSIN AS
YOU MENTION MANDELLA BARNES,
THAT IS THE BEST PERSON THAT
RON JOHNSON COULD'VE POSSIBLY
HOPE TO RUN AGAINST AND THEY ARE
STILL NOMINATING HIM, SOME
CANDIDATES DROPPED OUT AND GAVE
IT TO HIM AND HE HAS A JEREMIAH
PROBLEM, BUT SO DOES THE
AMERICAN SPEECH WAS CHRISTIAN
IMPEACHING AT ITS BEST.
I THINK THAT THE REPUBLICANS
WILL RUN THE TABLES IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE AND THEY WILL
HAVE A MAJORITY IN THE POLLS
ALWAYS OVERESTIMATING THE
STRENGTH OF REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES AND THE LACK OF
INTEREST AND INSPIRATION BY
THESE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE SO
OUTSIDE THE MAINSTREAM, GIVING
OUT A GREAT RUN TO THAT FEMALE
DEMOCRAT IN NEVADA WITH THREE
NAMES AND NO ACCOMPLISHMENTS,
BLAKE MASTERS PUMMELED,
COMPLETELY MADE A FOOL OUT OF
MARK KELLY IN THAT DEBATE, AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
CALL THEM OUT FOR THE LIES, 100%
VOTING RECORD WITH JOE BIDEN,
AND TRYING TO RUN AS A
DONALD TRUMP GUY ON TRADE,
FORGET ABOUT THAT.
I THINK WE HAVE GREAT CANDIDATES
THIS TIME AND THEY'RE GOING TO
WIN.
>> Jesse: TAKE IT TO THE BANK,
IF KELLYANNE CONWAY SAYS IT,
IT'S GUARANTEED.
>> STAY AWAY FROM THE EAGLES
CO